é eu vim falar aqui pra vocês sobre o
poder de transformação do design
principalmente o poder de transformação
do design na minha vida que fez eu me
transformar de uma designer curiosa a
uma empreendedora aprendiz
possibilitando a formação do meu negócio
da minha marca uma marca com o propósito
de trazer um novo o diferenciado algo
que fuja dos padrões que quebre
paradigmas de mercado e que traga a
inovação através da moda e do design e
da tecnologia é quebrando paradigmas
estéticos repensando a forma como
produzir um acessório como fazer um
acessório diferente como usar o
acessório de uma forma diferente e
também quebrando paradigmas produtivos
trazendo a impressão 3d como
protagonista no processo produtivos de
objetos diferenciados montando assim a
primeira marca orgulhosamente a primeira
marca de acessórios de impressão 3d
brasileira é mas porque o design o que
zaidi tem a ver com isso porque o design
influenciou tanto né nessa trajetória
para isso vou contar um pouquinho de
como eu conheci o design como ele entrou
na minha vida e por que ele me
influenciou uma maioria de vocês eu
passei por aquele momento de o que você
quando crescer
qual vai ser a minha profissão eu não
conhecia o design
eu não fazia idéia do que ele era apesar
de já ter tido algum contato com eles
sem nem ao menos saber a e ouvia a
partir de projeto a parte criativa com o
foco em arquitetura eu estava decidido a
fazer arquitetura a até que eu fui numa
feira de profissões junto com amigos que
ainda estava indeciso se eu tenho um
estande com uma caneta uma cadeira 111
eletrodomésticos um protótipo de carro e
aquilo me chamou a atenção
as possibilidades me chamaram a atenção
e ali eu vi que eu poderia desenhar
desde uma caneta tem um carro e isso me
inspirou
isso me gerou curiosidade eu falo que a
curiosidade me fez entrar de cabeça no
mundo do design e eu não tinha a mínima
daí o que ele ia me revelar durante todo
esse processo mas é eu fui me
apaixonando constantemente conforme os
anos foram passando e com essa gana de
fazer acontecer e eu fui atrás do meu
primeiro estágio tanto na universidade e
foi um baque porque foi uma desilusão
na verdade porque era um lugar aonde
eles copiavam muito do que vinha de fora
então eles iam para as feiras fora
traziam catálogos e falavam ah a gente
quer fazer algo parecido com isso não
existe um processo de criação um
processo de design desiludida voltei lá
pras minhas aulas e fui atrás de outro
outro estágio e eu falo que nesse
segundo estágio foi realmente onde
aconteceu a a minha escola de design que
foi onde eu aprendi o que era processo
como chegar realmente é na formação de
um produto final
todo bom design passa por um processo um
processo de pesquisa para você chegar
num conceito esse conceito você vai pro
desenhos manuais porque você tem que
tirar aquela ideia que aquele conceito
gerou da tua cabeça e pôr no papel e
depois você vai pra uma parte que é a
modelagem 3d que a parte de engenharia
de produto de produto realmente para daí
você começar a fazer protótipos e chegar
no consumidor final
então existe uma trajetória até você
chegar num produto final não era só
sentar desenhar e botar no mercado o que
eu falo também é que o design e me levou
a viajar na eu acabei saindo daquele
estágio porque o design me proporcionou
isso eu fui estudar fora do brasil na
itália no berço daquela profissão o que
era o design e eu falo que eu gosto de
colocar isso porque foi realmente um
marco muito importante porque eu evoluir
tanto profissionalmente porque estava
vivendo o que eu estudava aqui e também
é evoluir pessoalmente porque quebrou
muitos paradigmas meus de timidez a
próprio repertório que o adquire nesse
processo cultural é
nacional acabou se refletindo no que eu
estava projetando no que eu transmitir
para o meu consumidor final
então eu acredito muito que nossas
vivências refletem no que a gente vai
emanar pessoas ou emaná é prudente
tornado público e o meu jeito de
disseminar isso é através dos meus
produtos
voltando pra cá e depois desse
intercâmbio em universidades fora do
brasil
depois de um ano eu me formei e me vi
naquela muvuca de volta o que eu vou
fazer
para onde eu vou o que vou trabalhar né
enfim e acabei passando por diversos
setores sempre voltada design de produto
sempre voltada pra a projeto a aplikando
design da forma que eu aprendi mas
chegou um momento que aquilo não estava
mais me suprindo eu precisava de algo
mais
eu precisava de algo que me mover se e é
eu fui atrás de um curso de pós
graduação que era focada em design
centrado no usuário e me fez ver o
design além do processo que eu estava
acostumado a trabalhar me fez ver o
design como um processo muito mais
complexo
um processo que eu podia aplicar toda
aquela parte de pesquisa e de ação
conceituação além de um produto eu podia
fazer isso numa empresa remodelando um
processo empresarial eu podia fazer isso
remodelando aplicando essa ideologia
dentro de um aplicativo e repensando
como esse aplicativo pode melhorar a
vida das pessoas
o pude aplicar isso tanto de um produto
conceituando algo que seja benéfico para
o ego das pessoas de certa forma eu
descobri que o design
durante todo esse processo de conhecer
ele
ele era muito além do que o projetado
ele era os resignados car
ele era um processo de ressignificação
tanto para a melhoria de espaços quando
para melhoria de produtos quanto para
melhoria de empresas
o papel do designer é trazer o novo é
tentar trazer algo que melhore a vida
das pessoas
e aí que surgiu o primeiro por que não
eu estava no emprego e filme surgiu o
primeiro porque não preocupa porque não
vende gante na minha vida que foi porque
não presenciar algo novo eu estava
insatisfeita com o que eu estava fazendo
não estava mais me fazendo tão bem então
por que não trazer algo novo porque não
inovar porque não montar minha empresa o
meu negócio e criar produtos com
histórias criar produtos que ajudem as
pessoas criar produtos que as pessoas se
identifiquem né que as pessoas consigam
se expressar através daquelas peças e
foi nesse momento que eu vi que eu tinha
escolhido fazer uma que eu tinha feito
uma escolha sobre montar um dia 11 uma
marca um negócio e eu tive que mergulhar
em temáticas que não eram tão próximas a
mim como branding como manter novos
materiais como o marketing neco eu tenho
um produto x super bom mas eu não sei
vender aquele produto fica a guardar
dinheiro e ninguém compra então eu tive
que aprender sobre várias temáticas que
eu não estava acostumada e foi um
crescimento pessoal muito grande
além disso eu tive que me deparei com
isso né mas como fazer como nunca as
amargas o promg começar nem estava
emergindo em várias temáticas mas por
onde começar por onde começar sem grana
sem o investimento por trás como
empreender no brasil
tudo isso foi maranha de informações e
que me fez crescer muito e tudo isso eu
apliquei muito o processo de design né
a então vamos pesquisar vamos
desenvolver vamos chegar a um resultado
vamos pesquisar vão desenvolver e vamos
chegar a um resultado
um exemplo grande que eu trouxe aqui é a
questão do nome como a gente não tinha
grana a gente não tinha investimento
nós tínhamos que criar nós temos que
criar desde a logo marca desde o nome do
produto desde o marketing todas as
etapas da empresa era muito eu presa né
desde que a gente começou então o nome
eu trouxe um case porque ele é um
processo de design para ilustrar isso
pra vocês
a gente passou por uma etapa de pesquisa
que a gente partiu da idéia que a gente
está vendo contra-cultura de uma
joalheria de um acessório tradicional
a e descobriu é foi atrás de movimentos
contra cultura a partir dessa ideologia
descobriu uma dentro de um movimento uma
revista que chamava noiva andrez e foi
atrás mas porque esse nome porque esse
nome porque esse nome
descobriu se que era uma palavra enigma
dentro de um poema francês durante muito
tempo e que o significado dela garantido
ted
quando a gente leu isso a gente financia
tudo o que a gente estava querendo
propor para o mercado
a fuga dos padrões a fuga do ted e isso
também mostra um pouquinho como foi esse
processo de pesquisa conceituação e de
ação então a gente tenha uma história
pra contar
atrás desse nome isso é o que o design
faz contar uma história atrás de algo
que foi criado ali também trouxe uma
imagem das primeiras logomarcas e
mostrando que foi agente que criou
também porque a gente não tinha grana
pra isso eu gosto de falar também que as
redes sociais foram importantíssimas
desde o primeiro passo assim não ele
nesse mundo que a gente vive na internet
né a gente não tinha noção do que é de
que a gente tinha público como a
primeira marca brasileira de acessórios
a gente não tinha noção que a gente
tinha público ea gente teria aceitação
como seria a aceitação a gente tava
pegando na época com dourado metal e
pedra ea gente estava entrando com
plástico nylon fosco e preto basicamente
então era uma quebra de paradigma
gigantescas e nem se falava sobre
impressão 3d as pessoas não entendiam
então eu coloco aqui as redes sociais
como algo muito importante e muito
marcante porque a gente nasceu na
internet ea nossa comunicação direta com
o nosso público é na internet
a gente vende pela internet então ela é
algo que fez a noiva crescer fez
acontecer
e também me fez crescer e acontecer como
designer porque eu tinha o contato
direto com o meu consumidor final e eu
sabia como mexer com o que trazer pra
ele porque o meu foco de produto era
voltado para o usuário final
outras temáticas que eu tive que imagina
essa loucura de mim me meter nesse mundo
do empreendedorismo foram temáticas
uma startup network colaboração para a
parte financeira a parte empresarial né
todas as temáticas muito novas para mim
eu era uma designer eu sabia projetar
atrás do computador e eu estava virando
uma empreendedora e eu falo que estas
temáticas foram muito importantes porque
foi nesse momento de descobrir essas
temáticas que eu me vi nesse processo de
transformação de designer curiosa a
empreendedora aprende se fala que o
marco muito importante foi quando a
gente foi a gente nossa primeiro
escritório foi à biblioteca de uma
universidade porque era o lugar do meio
entre a minha casa a casa da minha sócia
então a gente se encontrava de noite lá
pra fazer a ao planejamento da empresa
ea gente toma a decisão de ir para um
colóquio onde tinham várias empresas ao
nosso redor
tinham várias pessoas ao nosso redor
eles olhavam pra gente falava meninas
vocês estão planejando planejando
planejando mas vocês têm um produto na
mão você tem que botar o pé no mercado e
testar é muito lento na localidade de
startup né você pegar o produto com o
mínimo produto viável o mvp que eles
falam e botar no mercado testar e ver se
você vai por esse caminho mesmo ou você
pode fazer uma manobra ele parte para
outro caminho e foi uma quebra de
paradigmas porque eu tinha um pensamento
eu tenho que deixar tudo perfeito para
de lançar e bombar a empresa e quando a
gente tomou coragem de fazer isso de a
perder o medo de compartilhar né é foi
sensacional porque a gente começou a
recolher feedback das pessoas ea gente e
eu percebi que uma empresa é um
organismo mutantes né a gente acha que
vai ser de uma determinada maneira
mas ele vai se mudando conforme o tempo
vai passando conforme o público vai te
direcionando conforme é o mercado vai te
direcionando né então foi muito
importante esse processo eu percebi que
além de tudo a gente não adianta a gente
fazer toda aquele planejamento de design
de marketing de brand em que aquilo que
é que eu como designer mais gosto né
a parte criativa
a parte estratégica tinha que pensar a
business tinha que pensar números tinha
que pensar processos
tinha que pensar como é que eu vou fazer
o meu produto quais materiais quais os
custos negociação com o fornecedor e
existe toda essa parte chata por trás
mas que se você não faz o teu negócio
não roda não é mesmo
pensar a tecnologia no nosso caso é
quando a gente começou a gente imprime a
fora do brasil porque era cómodo pra
gente a gente é tem gráficos de
impressão 3d fora e quando a gente toma
a decisão de nacionalizar foi uma
barreira gigantesca porque a gente teve
chegou pra é pessoas que trabalham com
grandes indústrias e falou nós queremos
fazer peças e acessórios feitos por
impressão 3d porque grandes indústrias
porque basicamente é o tipo de impressão
3d que a gente utiliza no brasil a usar
só prototipagem para a grande indústria
então digamos assim uma grande indústria
lá vai fazer uma peça de carro antes
dele executar uma peça em grande escala
vai de impressão 3d e faz e a gente
chegou pra esse produtor e falou olha
nós queremos fazer acessórios para o
público final
não cabia na cabeça desse produtores
porque era algo que não acontecia no
brasil
então foi uma barreira que a gente teve
que passar e descobrir as tecnologias
também descobri que existe mais de um
tipo de impressão 3d e qual dele a gente
vai utilizar né o pequenininho de mesa
que todo mundo conhece um intermediário
que trabalha com resina líquida um
realmente industrial que quase ninguém
conhece mas que vai permitir uma
complexidade de peça vai permitir uma
qualidade de peça uma resistência
mecânica e uma resistência calor a gente
optou por esse então a gente chegou em
nono em mais um porque não né
por que não usar a tecnologia por que
não entrar nessa nova era onde a
impressão 3d não é mais uma tendência é
uma realidade e criamos assim todo esse
processo fez com que eu criasse um
empresa além é uma empresa que cria
desenha desenvolve produz vende
acessórios contemporâneos feitos por
impressão 3d trazendo inovação para o
mercado unindo design moda e tecnologia
eu gosto de falar que desde que eu
comecei quando eu era uma designer
aprendiz até quando eu e me tornei ou
estou me tornando um empreendedor é uma
empreendedora aprendiz é o caminho não
foi linear
não foi algo maravilhoso perfeito
tiveram seus altos e baixos tiveram dias
que eu acordei falando nossa vamos fazer
isso que massa não sei que tiveram dias
que falava cara que vontade de desistir
é porque eu acho que existe muito isso
no empreendedorismo e eu aprendi isso
com o tempo o empreendedor ele é
resiliente
ele acredita naquilo ele quer fazer
aquilo acontecer e é isso que me move na
verdade e eu gosto de falar também né
que nem todo esse processo é voltando
pro design e porque ele me transformou
eu sempre trabalho design em todos os
pontos de contato da minha empresa eu
sempre trabalho pensamento design porque
hoje se for pensar com aquela
mentalidade que eu comecei achando que o
designer projeto 10% do que eu faço é
projeto é fazer um projeto executado um
projeto é de um produto e 90% é processo
mas sempre é design e eu gostaria de
deixar aqui um questionamento na verdade
pra vocês aí que tem ideias novas ou que
querem botar ideias novas
aí pra rodar é o que eu quero deixar é a
seguinte mensagem se permitam permitam à
risca permitam compartilhar com quem
está à sua volta e se permitam sempre
questionar por que não fazer diferente
obrigada